- Les leaders réunis au Sommet
de l'APEriririririririririririr,
inflation et crise énergétique.
À peine rassemblés à Bangkok,
un incident vient s'ajouter
à
- North Korea fired a ballistic
missile on Friday...
- La Corée du Nord a lancé
un missile balistique qui est
contrôlée par le Japon.
Le premier ministre japonais
a dénoncé lea a a a a a a a a a.
À l'APEC, les États-Unis ont
convoqué une réunion d'urgence.
La vice-prée e e e américaine
a condamné des actions illégales
visant à déstabiliser la région.
la plus forte intention
les actes irresponsables
de la Corée du Nord.
- Un rappel de l'instabilité
et des tensions qui persistent
- Canada is a reliable...
- Pour y faire face,
le gouvernement Trudeau s'engage
à y renfolilililililililililili,
sans détailler sa promesse.
Le Canada investira plus
de 90 millions de dollars
po
diplomatique.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- On démontre qu'on est
dans la région pour assurer
la stabilité qui va amener p
de prospérité pour les Canadiens
et pour les gens dans la région.
s'achève; des dizaines
de missiles russes
lancés sur l'Ukraine
en plein sommet du G20...
(en anglais)
avec le président chinois
et un tir de mis
par la Corée du Nord.
Alors que les régimes
chercher la confrontation,
Justin T p p p promet de
continuer à passer ses messages,
lui qui s'envole pour
le Sommet de la Francophonie.
Un p p p pays dont le leader
est critiqué pour un recul
des droits démocratiques.
mes préoccupations parppppppppoe
qu'on est en train de voir
dans bien des parties du monavac
ce qui se passe en Tunisie.
- Une autre destination,
une autre chorégraphie délicatee
la semaine, le premier ministre
a cherché à défendre ses valeurs
tout en essayant de trouver dea.
Dans un monde plombé par
des tensions géopolitiques,
de la diplomatie :
vevevever l'équilibre
entre fermeté et dialogue.
Bangkok, en Thaïland